Saudi wants it to be one of the biggest
flotation zeffer a 1-2-3 percent stake
in state-owned oil company Aramco which
could be worth more than twenty billion
dollars but although early November is
when the process is expected to start
the kingdom is giving little away it
will come in the right time with the
right approach and definitely with the
right decision and it will be a solid
decision
first and foremost specifically prism
hammered decision Crown Prince Mohammed
bin Salman wants Aramco valued at two
trillion dollars he's aiming to raise a
hundred billion dollars for ambitious
redevelopment plans for Saudi Arabia
bankers say between 1.2 and 1.5 trillion
is a more realistic valuation for Aramco
there is hesitation on the part of the
would-be investors they say until we see
an independent and international audit
evaluating Saudi proven reserves we are
not going to go ahead and spend that
huge sum of money on investment
indeed Norway's sovereign wealth fund
which is shedding many oil and gas
investments says it won't buy into
Aramco and Russia's sovereign wealth
fund isn't looking hugely keen either I
wouldn't talk about a need for an inker
investment because Aramco is generating
lots of interest including from our
partners in China and other Asian
economies indefinitely Russia will not
be making a huge investment in Aramco
because already it is quite exposed to
oil haram cows flotation was previously
delayed to give more time to find
international investors big players have
returns to Riyadh future investment
initiative forum many stayed away last
year because of the murder of journalist
Jamal khashoggi but other concerns might
be harder for investors to shake than
any they may have had over the killing
future oil prices are one September's
drone attacks on Aramco facilities are
another Aramco's IPO will be a test of
calm
evidence in the kingdom will reach
Alan's how to zero okay let's talk now
to Geoff Colgan Geoff is the associate
professor of political sciences at the
Brown University we focuses on
international order oil and energy he
joins us from Providence Rhode Island
Jeff welcome back to al-jazeera
who's got the valuation of Aramco right
or wrong here thanks so much for having
me on I think that Norway and Russia are
wise to stay away given their position
and they have real concerns multiple
concerns about investing further in the
oil sector Norway particularly think is
concerned about climate change and the
risk of stranded assets that that that
environmental risk raises okay also the
region across the board isn't at the
most settle that's been over the past
decade or so on Norway and the Russians
are sort of blending that into their
thinking as well certainly and the
facility that around Gowins you know
just a few weeks ago is is a real
concern Aramco's done a good job of
repairing the damage but the prospect of
another attack has to be looming on
investors minds and so Norway is is very
clearly not interested in investing
further Russia's being a little bit more
polite you know they're saying oh look
you know others are interested but but
we we aren't interested in in part
that's because I think Russia is keen to
keep on good terms cordial terms for
potential future cooperation with the
Saudis is there anything that Saudi
Arabia can do here if it wanted to in
your opinion that would make the
Russians and the Norwegians less
disposed to limit their exposure yeah I
think that the the Saudis need to have a
track record of you know calmer waters
and so this last you know six months
have been really tumultuous in the
region and in Saudi Arabia in particular
maybe even the last year and
so if if the leadership in Saudi Arabia
is keen on demonstrating that there is
rule of law that there is steady
investment that there's gonna be a
predictable return that's the kind of
thing that they need to establish with
just some calmer time and if I were them
I would think about doing that first
before leaning heavily on international
investors right now it seems like their
strategy is to turn towards investment
by Saudi nationals principally I'm
interested in this idea that you know it
might be a learning curve in some senses
for the Saudis I mean if you are Saudi
Arabia you know by definition you are
OPEC and is it your sense that the
Saudis have always been used to other
countries going to them and saying yes
we will work with you and it's kind of
tough for the Saudis to get a handle on
people as powerful as the Russians and
as wealthy as the Norwegians because the
the Norwegian sovereign fund is worth an
awful lot of money based on gas and oil
at the North Sea I think I've got that
one right you know for those two
countries the center has they actually
no we don't want to diversify even
though you need to and you want us to
that's right and I think in the Norway
region sovereign wealth fund is the
largest one in the world so you're
absolutely correct about that and so
when they say you know we're not
interested I think that sends a signal
although in in fairness Norway is that
the pension fund in particular is saying
you know we're trying to move away from
fossil fuels in general so it's not just
Saudi Arabia in fur for Norway with
Russia the the issue I think is a real
signal saying listen this is a
tumultuous situation and Russia's being
cautious about it even though again
they're they're being quite polite about
how they decline the opportunity and
that may ruffle some feathers in Saudi
Arabia where as you say they are
accustomed to a certain status on the
world stage and at the very center of
OPEC but I expect that they will have a
little bit of a harder time courting
international investors while they've
had so much
to molt around around come in the last
year Jeff good to talk to you thank you
so much